I'm Michael Stanislavski chair of CC and
I'm delighted to welcome you to the
second and last course wide lecture for
this academic year I'm delighted that
our speaker accepted our invitation to
come because I had wanted to have him
and hadn't had the chance to invite him
for all of the four years that I served
as chair of CC so so this is my last one
too but all I get to do is to introduce
so Robert Richards is the morris
fishbein professor of the history of
science and medicine at the University
of Chicago he is a member of the
department's of history in psychology
and director of the fish brain Center
for the history of science
his research spans the breadth of the
history and philosophy of psychology and
biology with specific interests in
evolutionary theory and biopsychology
ethology and sociobiology he has written
several books on the impact of
evolutionary theory and on German
intellectual thought including the
tragic sense of life ernst haeckel and
the struggle over evolutionary thought
which was published just a couple of
years ago the romantic conception of
life science and philosophy in the age
of Goethe the meaning of evolution the
morphological construction and
ideological reconstruction of darwin's
theory and Darwin and the emergence of
evolutionary theories of mind and
behavior currently professor Richards is
co-authoring a book entitled debating
Darwin with Michael ruse so with us and
please turn the podium over to him
well I hope we will indeed have
something of a debate I'm delighted to
be here at Columbia Columbia University
is one of the significant universities
in the United States along with the
University of Chicago that takes liberal
education quite seriously and this is
certainly an example of the seriousness
with which you take this kind of
education in the preface to his play
back to Methuselah in 1921 George
Bernard Shaw expressed his centuries
growing fear of that terminating machine
of Darwinism Shaw wrote you cannot
understand Moses without imagination in
our spiritual it was a famous preacher
of the day without metaphysics but you
can be a thoroughgoing neo-darwinian
without imagination metaphysics poetry
conscience or decency for natural
selection has no moral significance it
deals with that part of evolution which
has no purpose no intelligence and might
more appropriately be called accidental
selection our better is still unnatural
selection since nothing is more
unnatural than an accident if it could
be proved that the whole universe had
been produced by such selection only
fools and Rascals could bear to live
well one of those Rascals who seems to
be able to take it is Dan Dennett a
prominent philosopher of science in his
book Darwin's dangerous idea Dennett
affirms Shaw's characterization of
Darwin's accomplishment he writes Darwin
explains a world of final causes and
teleological laws with a principle that
is to be sure mechanical but more
fundamentally utterly independent of
meaning our purpose it assumes a world
that is absurd in the existentialist
sense of that term not ludicrous but
pointless and this assumption is a
necessary condition of any non question
beggining begging account of purpose now
this is
quite common assessment of Darwin's
accomplishment and when you have
opportunity to take up at least portions
of the Origin of Species you're going to
come to that book I suspect with a
mindset that has already been pre
conditioned to think about Darwin's
accomplishment in these terms namely the
Darwin banished notions of purpose and
teleology from the scientific
understanding of nature that he
introduced blind mechanical processes to
explain the descent of species in his
world human beings at least you will
assume this I presume I have no special
place indeed our evolution is assumed to
be highly contingent it could have been
the case that at the present time only
cockroaches inhabited this world that
our presence here is simply an accident
now I don't think that Shaw and Dennett
are correct and what I'm going to try to
argue with you today is that in the
Darwinian world one can still he'll hear
the sweet birds sing Darwinian nature at
least as originally conceived by its
author is not bereft of moral values as
both Shaw and Dennett presume indeed
this is the common presumption of both
opponents and supporters of Darwinian
evolution I rather think that their
Darwin demonstrated the power of mind in
nature
Darwin was indeed a an individual who
ushered in the modern world but I think
what needs to be stressed is that he was
also one whose values assumptions and
whose science was formed in the
pre-modern world of the early part of
the 19th century so let me briefly
attempt to show you that Darwin
constructed his theory using conceptions
of a rather traditional sort and when
one comes to understand what the
instruments of his construction were the
whole ball pawn appears I think in a
rather different light not quite so
harsh are as impervious to human
aspiration
not quite so meaningless as Shaw and
Dennett believe so what were the
instruments of his construction of his
theory well first of all Chile illogical
causality
now I presume that given your experience
in the core curriculum that you followed
the ideas of Aristotle are not at least
too distant from your intellectual
horizons so geological causality is one
of those kinds of causality that
Aristotle introduced low those centuries
ago but was assumed by Dennett and many
others to have been banished from the
repertoire of biologists certainly by
the time you've got to Darwin and Darwin
himself is purported to have excluded
appeals to teleological causality in
order to understand the operations of
nature what I'm going to argue is that
Darwin's theory does not dispense with
teleological notions that human beings
are as it were the trajectory toward
which nature is aiming at least that's
the way Darwin constructs it and that
there is a deep moral character to
Darwin's understanding of nature now
Darwin obliquely expresses this
trajectory in that famous pair raishin
that concludes the Origin of Species as
he says from the laws of variability
divergence of character and natural
selection these are the laws that he has
discriminated in his book the Origin of
Species he assumes the most exalted
object which were capable of conceiving
namely the production of the higher
animals directly follows there's
grandeur in this view of life with its
several powers having been breathed
originally into a few forms or into one
and that whilst this planet has gone
cycling on according to the fixed laws
of gravity from so simple a beginning
endless forms most beautiful and most
wonderful have been and are being
evolved the most exalted object which
were capable of conceiving is us
we are that highest animal human beings
particularly with their Moral Sentiments
that's to say man as a moral animal I
think is the teleological goal of nature
as Darwin's theory constructs it now
needless to say perhaps this is not the
usual picture of Darwin's accomplishment
he's most often represented by the likes
of Michael Gillan Stephen Jay Gould
Richard Liu Anton Richard Dawkins
Michael roost and Dennett and a host of
others as having banished teleology from
nature as having constructed natural
selection as a blind mechanistic process
that eradicated the least tincture of
non selfish behavior from human beings
an exemplar of this kind of attitude is
that of Michael dicen who so delicately
put it in the Darwinian world scratch an
altruist and watch a hypocrite bleed
while the aforementioned scientists and
philosophers emphasize the distally
ology and a moral implications of
Darwinism there are some like philip
pitcher here at columbia our george
levine whose last book bears the title
darwin loves you these are individuals
who think there are replacements for
what darwin seems to have swept away
namely a structure of scientific and
philosophical considerations that pump
meaning back into life and leave human
beings as intrinsically ethical
creatures now I would generally cast my
lot with Phil catcher and George Lavigne
but but not entirely since they too have
been ready to accept what I take to be
the neo-darwinian interpretation of
Charles Darwin's theory and perhaps it's
needless to say but bears saying again
Darwin was not a neo-darwinian as I
mentioned I believe Darwin in fact
constructed nature as having a goal and
end human beings as moral creatures
moreover he advanced a view of
human nature that made human beings
authentically moral creatures not
hypocritically selfish with a facade of
altruism but as deeply authentic
altruist now before detailing the the
argument for these conclusions let me
just say a few brief words about
darwin's early life Darwin was born in
18 in 1809 he was the son of Robert
Waring Darwin a rather well-known
Shrewsbury physician he was the grandson
of the even more famous Erasmus Darwin
who himself had developed a theory of
species change Darwin
followed his grandfather his father and
his elder brother to Edinburgh Medical
School in 1825 Charles lasted only two
years at Edinburgh
it was a dreadful experience in his
perfectly charming autobiography Darwin
recalls the horror of rising very early
in the morning at and taking lectures at
8 o'clock on materia medica on a
winter's morning in Edinburgh that was
enough along with some experiences he
had of open surgeries without anesthesia
anesthesia hadn't been developed at this
point that after two years he had enough
and he came down from Edinboro without a
degree
he was a great disappointment to his
father since the family traditionally
had gone to Edinboro and had produced a
number of prominent physicians in his
autobiography Darwin recalled that once
his father said to him you care for
nothing but shooting dogs and
rat-catching and you'll be a disgrace to
yourself and all your family Darwin
quickly added but my father who was the
kindest man I ever knew and whose memory
I loved with all my heart must have been
angry and somewhat unjust when he used
such words after failure at medical
school
Darwin enrolled at Cambridge University
with the vague idea of becoming a
country parson he spent most of his
time at Cambridge in pursuit of those
things his father had warned him against
mostly going to dinner parties but
collecting beetles Darwin recounts in
his autobiography that he had no
systematic purpose in collecting beetles
he just liked to collect bugs he tells
the story of one afternoon late
afternoon when he was in the backs
behind Christ College at Cambridge and
he saw a beetle and he picked it up
because it looked like a wonderful
addition to his collection
and then he saw another one and picked
that up and on his way back to the
College he kicked over a stone and saw
one that he simply could not dispense
with and then the one in his right hand
he popped into his mouth to pick up the
other one but the one in his mouth exude
in some acrid fluid and he lost all
three beetles well he simply indicates
that to suggest the avidity with which
he collected beetles when Darwin was a
senior at Cambridge he had by chance
read the autobiographical reminiscences
of alexander von humboldt humboldt had
traveled to the new world in 1799 and
wrote hobbit in a multi-volume
autobiography alexander von humboldt was
a protege of johann wolfgang von goethe
and he was a prominent and eminent
scientist but he was also a romantic
adventurer and when darwin picked up
these volumes he himself was inspired to
think about the possibility this is this
very parochial of parochial lad about
wider horizons he certainly didn't have
really harbor much hope of exercising
those desires but as chance had it the
opportunity came to ship out on a boat
that was going to fly the coast of South
America to chart the waters for British
merchant shipping HMS Beagle and Darwin
eventually was hired actually hired as
the wrong
way to put it because he had to pay his
own way to act as naturalist and
companion to the mercurial captain of
the ship Robert Fitzroy Fitzroy was a
manic-depressive man and Darwin never
never quite got on his good side
Darwin's father had to pay the freight
though because this was something that
he was not hired to do in order to go he
Darwin's father had to come up with some
cash and that immediately constrained
him and it took a great deal of
convincing and coaxing to allow Darwin
to take the trip the trip was to be for
two years it was going to go from
England to South America to chart the
waters off the coast of South America a
trip around the world
ultimately it was to last two years but
wound up going over a period of almost
five years during the time that Darwin
spent on the Beagle his biology would
appear to have remained perfectly
Orthodox that is he believed in the
stability of species he collected a
number of specimens that is the ship
would dock at various ports on the coast
of South America and Darwin would get on
his horse or donkey depending on what
was available go inland he would do some
geology Seng he would collect specimens
flora and fauna pack them up and send
them back on merchant merchant ships
back to England in the British Museum
when Darwin returned he after visiting
for example but a lot famously the
Galapagos Islands he nonetheless as I
say probably remained Orthodox in his
biology it was only after he returned
and he started cataloging his specimens
that he began to think about the
possibility of species change when he
was describing his mockingbirds
three varieties of one species when
Darwin went to the Galapagos he was
persuaded that the Galapagos were
volcanic Lee produced these were
volcanic islands and he thought them to
be about a million years old
now by the time Darwin is writing
geologists of the period had already
decided that the calculations of the age
of the earth of say six thousand years
by Bishop Ussher were really quite
ridiculous and that most professional
geologists recognized that the the world
was very very old and Darwin's own
estimate of those islands was as about a
million years old and pretty sharp he
was because we now think them to be
about a million and a half years old he
conceived that the animals on the
islands mostly birds lizards tortoises
that they probably came over from the
mainland the birds may have gotten blown
over by some storm and landed on the
various islands and had lived there for
eons one of the characteristics of birds
on the Galapagos if any of you have
traveled to the Galapagos you know this
quite well the birds have no fear of
human beings if you're walking along a
path on one of the islands some birds
may be in the way you have to step over
them they don't get out of your way
Darwin and collecting specimens could do
it quite easily he would just go up to a
tree where a hawk or a Mockingbird
happened to be sitting take the butt of
his rifle knock it on the head into a
bag and then take it back to the ship
and then prepare it in spirits of wine
to be sent back to to England so the
birds were quite tamed but these mocking
birds Darwin thought that probably in
the long distant past one species got
blown over to the island and they
settled on very the various of the
islands and because of the impact of the
environment the varieties changed now
within the biology of the period it
would be perfectly Orthodox to maintain
that environmental changes could induce
morphological changes and produce new
varieties within a species but the
species barriers themselves could not be
breached when Darwin got back he was
cataloguing his specimens and consulting
with John Gould one of the world's
leading ornithologist at the British
Museum and Gould said that these birds
were
not varieties of one species these were
good and distinct species
this obviously tripped a mind at the
ready Darwin had been perfectly
cognizant of earlier attempts to
formulate a theory of species change
over time his own grandfather Erasmus
had produced such a theory more famously
perhaps john baptiste de la Marck had
constructed such a theory Darwin himself
was not original and maintaining or
arguing that species changed over time
but the views of these two individuals
had been derided they were not accepted
at all in the intellectual communities
of Britain and France but now Darwin
primed with the knowledge of his
mockingbirds which he had a good theory
about how they got on the islands and
how they changed but now he saw the
change to be had to have been more
drastic and so with the background of
his grandfather and Lamarck's ideas he
began to formulate for himself notions
of species change he first explored what
would be the causes of this change and
initially Darwin had what we would take
to be Lamarckian notions of the causes
of such change namely the effects of the
environment which are inherited by
groups of organisms which pass them on
to their offspring so this is a view of
the inheritance of acquired
characteristics Darwin never let go of
that idea
Darwin was in one way we would think of
as a very conservative thinker that idea
is once formulated he never really
abolished though he transmuted them in
several ways so from the beginning of
his career to the end Darwin believed in
the inheritance of acquired
characteristics that's not something
that he dismissed but in 1838 in late
September of that year he picked up as
he said for amusement thomas malthus's
essay on the principle of population now
Darwin as they said said he picked it up
for amusement indicating he had a very
low bar for amusement
the
book led him to formulate what we now
know as the principle of natural
selection very early in Darwin's
theories him he had been aware that the
breeders picking our choosing could
transform the structure of animals and
plants but initially he had no way of
conceiving how that process might take
place in nature
what Malthus provided was the notion of
species pressure they namely that more
individuals are born in a generation
than can possibly be supported by the
environment which meant as Darwin
conceived it that any slight trait that
an organism might have that gave it an
advantage over others of its generation
would allow that animal to have a better
probability of reaching reproductive age
and passing those traits on to offspring
and this essentially is the idea behind
natural selection now this is the usual
way in which Darwin's theory is put and
it's certainly I think the case but
below that is a deeper structure and
it's that deeper structure that I'd like
to try to expose today just to keep you
aware of his trajectory in from 1837 to
1847 kept a series of notebooks in which
he was working out his notions of
species change and these notebooks
rather prosaically are called the a the
B C D and E notebooks as well as
notebooks M&N in 1842 he sits down to
write an essay which is going to be
essentially the essay that is the
foundation for the book Origin of
Species he this about 35 manuscript
pages two years later he writes out a
much longer essay developing ideas that
are nascent in the first essay he has a
fair copy made a fair copy as
a copy that a printer could use to print
a book and he leaves 400 pounds in his
will that should he die before this
growing theory was announced to the
public that posthumously the book could
be printed so he leaves 400 pounds but
Darwin lives and lives a very long time
from 1848 to 1854 Darwin gets
sidetracked he's going to he wants to
give a description of a barnacle that he
discovered on his voyage and he winds up
describing all the known extant
particles and extinct barnacles
available through the paleontological
record and produces ultimately for large
monographs on barnacles this is a kind
of sidetrack that if you go to the
university library you can still find
his volumes there and they're probably
there's still the last word on the
description of barnacles in 1856 he
really he sits down to start working on
his theory and to write it out in a
large manuscript and from 1856 to 58 he
produces a manuscript that the pages are
piling up he was going to call it
natural selection and had he finished it
it would have been at least a two maybe
a three volume work but in 1858 he got a
letter from an obscure naturalist
working in Barney Oh Alfred Russel
Wallace and in the letter Wallace says
you know I have a notion about species
change and he included a little essay
and he writes Darwin mr. Darwin if you
think there's anything to this would you
communicate this to Sir Charles Lyell
while being one of the most prominent
scientists of the period and a friend of
Darwin's when Darwin read the essay he
about died he said it's as if Wallace
were standing behind me and reading over
my shoulder out of my notebooks
theories were so similar Darwin was
crestfallen he thought his originality
had been swiped from him and he thought
that honor required him to stop working
on his own theory his friends had to
convince them and probably they didn't
have to convince him too much no we know
you've been working on this for a long
time and they arranged to have Wallace's
essay and passages out of Darwin's 1844
essay read to the Linnaean Society it
was pretty clear given the dating of
Darwin's essay and they made sure that
that dating was pretty prominent that
Darwin had really gotten there first the
essays were read before the society they
were printed in a society journal at the
end of the year the Secretary of the
Linnaean Society summarized the
activities of that year and he said a
pretty dull year nothing important has
happened well Darwin then quickly
compresses this large manuscript that he
is writing he got to about what amounts
to chapter 7 of the origin that we have
and that he adds the rest of the
chapters and in 1859 he publishes the
Origin of Species calls it an abstract
in the 1860s he works on the variation
of plants and animals that is he wants
to try to figure out how it is that
animals spontaneously seemed to be
variable as they are born and in 1871 he
attacks a problem and a topic that he
had purposely neglected in the Origin of
Species and that is the evolution of
human beings if you've read any of the
Origin you know that Darwin does not
talk about except in one rather limited
way about human evolution he made a
decision that he did not want to talk
about human evolution in the Origin
because he thought that everybody would
focus on that and that it would distract
from the
the arguments that he was making for the
reality generally of the evolutionary
process well as soon as the origin was
published of course all the reviewers
focused only what on what the
implications were for human beings so he
was forted in that respect and finally
came out with the descent of man in 1871
now if we go back and look at some of
his early notes books I think the
structure of the origin becomes much
more obvious so here is a passage from
his a notebook in which he writes and
here he's working on a certain problem
it's a problem that biologists today are
still quite curious about and I suspect
many in this audience or even curious
about and the problem is why is there
sex that is a more primitive form of
reproduction is what we would call
clonal reproduction that is asexual
reproduction budding efficient and so
forth engaged in for example by a lot of
invertebrates so the question is why
wasn't that the predominant mode of
reproduction what is the origin of
sexuality and in his notebook Darwin
speculates about this and he forms an
argument and this is the argument he
says my theory gives great final cause
of sexes for otherwise there would be as
many species as individuals and what he
seems to have thought is that through
asexual reproduction
each individual would be like an
individual species and he goes on if all
species that is if all individuals were
species then there would not be social
animals which as I hope to show is the
foundation of all that is most beautiful
in the Moral Sentiments of the animated
beings if man is one great object for
which the world was brought into present
state that is one great purpose for
which the world is brought into present
state and if my theory be true than the
formation of sex is rigidly necessary
now this is a perfectly teleological
argument
sex came to exist sexual reproduction in
order that there be social animals
social animals came into existence in
order that there be moral animals and of
course the moral animal is us that is
his theory indicates the great object of
all this namely the object for which the
world was brought into present state
namely human beings now if we dig down
into the layers of the Origin of Species
for example if we start off with that
peroration at the end of the origin
where darwin talks about the most
exalted object were capable of
conceiving namely the production of the
higher animals we can trace down I mean
the the origin is like an archaeological
deposit you can move down to the earlier
incarnations of certain of the sentences
in the book and you find at the lowest
level is that a notebook passage man is
the one great object for which the world
was brought into present state which
suggests the kind of teleological
structuring that Darwin conceived nature
as having evinced now in the last
paragraph of the Origin you find that
passage and I think this kind of
archaeological layering suggests what is
at the bottom of it all man's trajectory
that is in the whole trajectory of
nature is the result of laws and the
laws that he has discriminated growth
with reproduction inheritance
variability the struggle for life and
natural selection Darwin's concept of
law is I think perfectly typical of what
you would find in the 19th century
namely a law demands a lawgiver when
Darwin was a student at Cambridge he had
to get up as he said certain books in
order to get a degree it was not an
honours degree it was the degree a
gentleman might take but he had to
a little William Paley who was a natural
theologian and that natural theologian
did indicate that the world came to be
through the establishment of certain
laws and the laws were promulgated by a
lawgiver namely God these notions of law
which you find in the origin I think and
from that perspective are quite typical
and what Darwin argues in the origin
which is perfectly palpable is that
these laws act as secondary causes which
require a primary cause namely God who
has established these laws this I think
is clear from one of the epigrams for
example that he takes from another
natural theologian William Yule and this
is an epigram for the Origin of Species
but with respect to the material world
we can at least go so far as this we can
perceive that events are brought about
not by insulated inter positions of
divine power exerted at each particular
case but by the establishment of general
law in the origin
Darwin frequently contrasts his theory
against that of natural theologians but
I think if you concentrate and if you've
already read some of the Origin you know
this to be the case and or you will know
it to be the case that what Darwin is
objecting to is the notion that God
intervened at each step to produce this
species than this species than this
species what he's contending is that all
of this comes about by the reason of
natural law which God is ultimately the
Tamil Gator of after the publication of
the origin Darwin writes his friend ASA
gray here in the United States gray was
a botanist and a prominent natural
theologian he said I'm inclined to look
at everything as resulting from design
laws with the details whether good or
bad left to the working out of what we
may call chance this was one way in
which Darwin was able to as it were
reconcile his theory with what is and
handle what was one of the great
problems since agustin to the present
time is why is there evil in the world
if the world is the product of a good
god ultimately how can there be evil
well at least the way Darwin begins to
conceive it is that God has established
laws which are indeed are very good but
these laws don't perfectly as it were
direct a contingent nature there are
things that will happen as it were
accidentally and that's the source of
evil at least this seems to be the way
Darwin is thinking about it so that it's
really by chance that evil occurs Darwin
and his autobiography indicates and says
that when I finished writing the Origin
of Species I still believed in an
intellectual power governing the world
but that belief dissipated in a
discussion he had toward the end of his
life with Edward Aveling abling was the
consort of Karl Marx's youngest daughter
and himself a biologist he visited
Darwin at his home and down and
discussed with him the problem of the
relationship of science and religion
Darwin was curious as why abling and his
friends thought of themselves as
atheists for Darwin's money
atheists know too much at this point in
the 1860s Darwin's faith which had waned
Darwin said the term that best captures
my own views is that of his friend
thomas henry huxley namely agnosticism
he's an agnostic by this time so darwin
confesses though that he lost his belief
in Christianity about in the 1850s
probably as a result of the death of his
favorite daughter Annie but he held on
to a rather theistic view until a short
time into the 1860s but then thereafter
that faded as well but I think the point
to be stressed and to brought he brought
home is that the construction of his
theory in the origin of
occurs under the aegis of this larger
idea of nature being governed by law and
these laws having an intellectual mental
source now let me turn just to a closer
examination of the concept of natural
selection in Darwin we we usually think
of natural selection as a rather simple
idea and in fact thomas henry huxley
darwin's friend after he read the Origin
of Species
literally virtually hit himself in the
head and said how stupid of me not to
have thought of this first it just
seemed to be so clear of course it took
490 pages in order to make it clear in
the essays of 1842 and 44 Darwin tries
to explain how it is that natural
selection operates and he uses the
breeders practice that is what we would
take to the artificial selection and he
became convinced of the great power of
artificial selection here is an example
of what artificial selection can do
these are pigeons they have their origin
in this common bird that you see begging
on the streets here of New York but with
the techniques of the pigeon fancier you
can produce produce really quite
extraordinary animals Darwin himself
collect started breeding pigeons in the
1850s because he wanted to be assured
that animals as it were were plastic and
could be molded by selection and this he
certainly demonstrated to himself and
you can see this in in the pigeons he
asked himself whether there was in
nature any process comparable and he
thinks about what the process might be
he says isn't nature is there any means
of selecting those offspring which vary
in the same manner crossing them and
keeping their offspring separate and
thus producing selected races otherwise
is the wild animals freely crossed so
must such small heterogeneous varieties
be constantly counterbalanced and lost
and a uniformity of character preserved
so what Darwin is worried about here is
just this a breeder will keep a large
flock he will see an animal that has
certain traits that appeals to him he'll
select that animal he'll see another
animal that has traits that are
comparable breed them together and
ultimately through the iteration of that
process you'll produce pigeons of the
sort that you just saw but the question
is what in nature as it were performs
this function what brings these animals
together if left to their own devices as
it were animals would breed with those
closest to them and any incipient
favorable traits would be swamped out by
breeding with animals that don't have
those traits or have as it were negative
values of those traits so the question
is what in nature performs this function
Darwin in his essays tries to figure out
this and he forms for himself a certain
model and here's the model that you find
say in the 1844 essay this is a model
for natural selection he says let us
suppose a being with penetration
sufficient to perceive differences in
the outer and inner most organization
quite imperceptible to man and with
forethought extending over future
centuries to watch with unerring care
and select for any object the offspring
of an organism produced under the
foregoing circumstances I can see no
conceivable reason why he could not form
a new race or several as he if he were
to separate stock all the original
organism and work on several islands
adapted to new ends as we assume his
discrimination his forethought and his
studying us of object to be incomparably
greater than those qualities and bands
so we may suppose the beauty and
complications of the adaptations of the
new race and their differences from the
original stock to be greater than in the
domestic race is produced by man's
agency with time enough such a being
might rationally without some unknown
law opposing him aim at almost any
result
no term comes more trippingly to our
lips when talking about natural
selection as the mechanism of natural
selection that phrase never came to
Darwin's lips as you can see the model
that he has formed for himself of the
operations of natural selection is a
model of a supreme intelligence
operating it operates with forethought
and discrimination and chooses with
unerring care the organisms under which
it has in tendons this is a model of
mind in nature it's not a model of a
machine like operation and when you turn
to the Origin of Species and this is
from the origin itself you see that
Darwin I won't go through this passage
but it is comparable to the passage that
you find in his essays that is he has
formed for himself a model of the axed
activity of a rational mind now here is
another passage from the origin and let
me just focus on that last phrase he
writes it may be said that natural
selection is daily and hourly
scrutinizing throughout the world every
variation even the slightest rejecting
that which is bad preserving and adding
up all that is good silently and
insensibly working whenever and wherever
opportunity offers at the improvement of
each organic being that line that
natural selection works for the
improvement of each organic being is in
one form or another appears several
times in the origin so here is just in
the penultimate paragraph of the Origin
another example of that and as natural
selection works solely by and for the
good of each being all corporeal and
mental endowments will tend to progress
towards perfection now at this point I'm
just going to ask you a question if
you've if you look at that very
carefully and some of you have taken
biology courses what strikes you about
that
yes are you yes you raising your hand
he's talking about an individual that's
exactly so very good we think of
evolution is having or a natural
selection having an effect on the
population level that's certainly true
okay I think you're really right on the
right track here both of you as a matter
of fact as natural selection works
solely by and for the good of each being
and each individual does as you were
beginning to go in that direction does
natural selection as we understand it
work for the good of each individual be
brave say it no I mean it eliminates
most individuals it destroys most
individuals that's the way we think
about natural selection but Darwin is so
imbued with the idea that this is a
moral process that he sees natural
selection is operating for the good of
each individual or for them as the
previous passage had it for the
improvement of each individual actually
what it does is just from our
perspective destroy most individuals
leaving a few standing as it were but
here he conceives of it rather
differently there's another feature of
about this if you've read any of Steve
gules wonderful essays and they are
indeed wonderful Gould produced or
preached the idea that evolution is not
a progressive activity it doesn't lead
to higher beings that's the way Steve
Gould formulates it but you see Darwin
doesn't think that at all
it leads to the progress toward
perfection in corporeal
and mental endowments so this is simply
an indication that when you actually
read the text and look at it and are not
as it were reading back in ideas we have
from the contemporary period we see
Darwin out quite different light let me
just summarize some of these ideas that
I have tried to indicate in a very brief
way
first of all natural selection operates
Darwin conceives it as a kind of agency
and a single force we think of natural
selection is operating as it were from a
multitude of environmental
causal relationships producing its
effect
natural selection operates as an agent
with intentional power and that's the
other feature of Darwin's notion of
modeling or at least the way he models
natural selection on an intelligent
force if Darwin modeled natural
selection on a machine machines work in
a rather desultory way they don't they
don't produce perfection so the machines
that Darwin would have had as examples
in the 19th century would not have been
machined they've something like a
Manchester spinning loom that's not
going to produce find a musk the the
perfection of the I probably could not
result from any machine like activity
but that intelligent force could perhaps
produce the perfection of the eye a
natural selection prevents back crosses
I won't go into that too much it shows
moral solicitude and this is an example
that I've just enunciated natural
selection produces general progress
which is again quite antithetic to our
usual view of Darwin's accomplishment
and certainly it's a late 20th century
view and 21st century view of the
character of evolution and it has a
final goal at least that's the way I'm
suggesting that Darwin initially
conceived it now let me just very
quickly and this will be quick talk
about the way Darwin conceives human
beings in the descent of man Darwin left
the question of human evolution to the
1870s and one of the characteristics of
human beings that he thought he had to
explain was first of all not man's
intelligence I mean when we think of our
distinction from the animals we think
that well we have human reason and
animals don't if you are a British
empiricist writing say in the 19th
century what do you take
reason and intelligence to be so this is
another question I'm gonna put to you
some of some of you have read maybe John
Stuart Mill or James mill or Jeremy
Bentham our David Hume what would
intelligence amount to any close
well so the silence is deafening so I
have to give you an answer he conceives
David Hume for example conceives ideas
as faint reflections of sensations and
that reasoning is really the association
of ideas and certainly in the early part
of the 19th century that was a common
enough view that even natural
theologians were want to ascribe a
little bit of reason even to insects so
that the barrier between human beings
and animals was not reason that could be
explained the barrier was morality that
is human beings were moral no animal is
a moral creature except human beings so
Darwin thought that he really had to
explain how morality could evolve now
right from the beginning he starts
speculating about how that could be the
case and he tries out a variety of ideas
nothing is really quite so satisfactory
I mean one of the characteristics of
morality as Darwin conceived it it has
to be altruistic acting for the good of
another at some expense to self that's
what it is to be moral
as far as Darwin is concerned so Darwin
tries out a lot of ideas and then in a
separate sort of intellectual
consideration he meets a problem in the
understanding of the social insects bees
and ants and here's the problem of the
social insects they have a variety of
traits so if you look at worker ants for
example there are soldier ants there are
workers and they have slightly different
anatomical characteristics the same
thing with worker bees and soldier bees
they have certain different anatomical
characteristics as well as different
instincts now the question is how did
natural selection produce those and I
put it to you what is the problem why
would Darwin stumble initially in trying
to figure out how natural selection
worked to produce the anatomical
characteristics of say worker and
soldier bees or worker in soldier ants
well okay so the answer he suggested
indeed this was part of the problem if
what what soldier bees do is a marauding
bear comes trying to break into the hive
the these soldiers go out and sting the
bear and of course what they do in
stinging the bear is eviscerate
themselves the stinger comes out as well
as their inside so they die natural
selection works such that if any trait
is beneficial to the individual that
individual will be able to pass it on to
its offspring dying is not a character
that is beneficial to the individual so
that's a problem there's even a more
fundamental problem though which is
those of you who have had any biology
but even if you haven't had biology
Kathy Rhea well not so much that they're
coming from the same hive but what's
characteristic of worker bees and ants
not quite there neuters exactly they
don't reproduce but natural selection
works on individuals to allow them to
reach reproductive age and pass those
traits on to their offspring neuter bees
and ants have no offspring so how can a
natural selection operate to produce
these anatomical traits through these
instincts displayed by the workers and
the soldiers in ant nest and beehives it
is perplexing but you know what the
answer is it's an answer that Darwin
struggled with and it only at the last
minute as it were solved and it's the
answer that we accept today and you get
extra credit if you know
okay basically you've got exactly the
right answer namely natural selection
works on the whole hive are on the whole
nest at one time because by chance if
that nest has say more aggressive bees
just by chance that nest is going to
have a better chance of surviving in a
competitive environment than other nests
that there's hives that don't have
aggressive bees when the Bears come to
maraud and it will survive new Queens
will be produced they'll go off and
establish new hives and those traits
will as it were disseminate in that
fashion and that will continue and be
reiterated over eons and therefore those
traits will become ever more refined and
will have ultimately honeybees and
worker bees and the hives and soldiers
so it's the natural selection works on
the whole hive or tribe when Darwin
solve this he also saw how this might
apply to human beings and here is whoops
here is the passage from the descent of
man that captures it there can be no
doubt that a tribe including many
members who from possessing a high
degree the spirit of patriotism fidelity
obedience courage and sympathy we're
always ready to give aid to each other
and to sacrifice themselves for the
common good would be victorious of
Rimowa most other tribes and this would
be natural selection at all times
throughout the world tribes have
supplanted other tribes and his morality
as one element in their success the
standard of morality and the number of
well-endowed men well thus everywhere
tend to rise and increase the way Darwin
conceived it is this that proto human
beings existed in small clans or tribes
those tribes and clans which by chance
had individuals who were more
cooperative would have a better chance
of reaching with surviving in their
environment and those tribes as they got
larger would split off form other groups
and that process would continue and
there by in this fashion you would get
altruistic behave
you're instilled in a human population
Darwin also thought that another kind of
evolution cultural evolution where
learning is passed from group to group
over the ages that that would allow
people to understand that it's just not
this person in this location who's a
member of my tribe it's that group
across the river they're no different
than I am and therefore the instincts
the social instincts the altruistic
instincts would be also operative for
those others across the river and that
process would continue and we would
through the growth of intelligence find
what is really at work in helping others
so we'll find out what is really
beneficial in this way Darwin formulated
a theory of morality which I think one
could recommend today it is a superb
theory so Darwin was that individual of
the 19th century he formulated a theory
that had if we were in a theater in
which we are indeed in a theater we
would say it had legs it really did
Purdue it was the theory that formed the
basis of virtually all of modern biology
there are resources in there
particularly Darwin's moral theory that
I think recommends itself for us today
but we have to keep in mind that Darwin
was indeed a man of his time he was a
child of the 19th century and his theory
is not necessarily that legatee that we
have inherited it it's different from
that but it's because of Darwin's
accomplishment that we have modern
biology today thank you very much
so you have let's see there's some in
the back here yeah that's fine hi thank
you for the lecture I was wondering
about Darwin's idea of perfection it
seems to me that perfection can only be
applied when you have a purpose to
achieve does he believe and if you
believes in perfection does he believe
in a purpose for the species well I
think Darwin the concept of perfection
is one that Darwin initially begins with
so in his early notebooks you see him
talking about through the process that
he has outlined perfection being
achieved after all the vertebrate eye
looks like a pretty extraordinary
accomplishment and in Paley's natural
theology something that Darwin had to
read as a student Paley uses the eye as
the example of a product that can only
be attributed to the Creator because it
is so well designed that there is no
other account that can be given except
the direct creation by God Darwin had to
argue that it could be created in
another fashion through the operation of
natural processes and he he he lost the
notion that perfection was achievable
that is whatever organism were talking
about could always be better but he
didn't lose the idea that there's a kind
of trajectory of improvement and the
vertebrate eye he was happy to note
hermann von helmholtz
great German physiologist polymath in
describing the I pointed out the
imperfections of the eye and that that
really satisfied Darwin a great deal
because he saw that the eye while it was
extraordinary in its design nonetheless
had imperfections which could be
attributed to the actions of nature
so he had a relative notion of
perfection but he did think that that
the natural processes were producing
greater progress and perfection so back
there again you touched a little bit on
Darwin's opinion regarding the evolution
of sex and but you never really sort of
came to the answer to his question and I
was just thinking that isn't the current
opinion nowadays that in environmentally
environments that are fluctuating
unstable environments greater variation
in genes causes give means a higher
likelihood of survival for a species and
me because of the process of sex and
meiosis and the gene pool basically
expands and so in fluctuating
environments it's preferable to have
sexually reproducing animals yes I mean
that that that is one of the tactics in
explaining why sexual Generation ie
evolved over long periods of time this
slight problem with that is bacteria do
quite well and they have been around
since the beginning and they have
changed a little bit and they have
evolved but nonetheless their means of
reproduction is quite simple and for the
most part asexual although I'm sure
you're going to tell me this that
occasionally they get together and
exchange genes which is something like
sexual reproduction so Darwin thought
when he was trying to he never himself I
think solved the problem to his
satisfaction but he did recognize that
in clonal reproduction if accidents
happen to an organism those accidents
that is unfavorable situations get
passed on as well so there is not the
means as Darwin says and that's really
close to what our contemporary notion is
is you've just explained it that there's
greater possibility of change there's
greater variability such that that can
be utilized now he didn't see that right
away and as it were the the I the
problem of sex sort of dropped out for
Darwin but ultimately he was moving in
the direction amazingly that we do today
I had a colleague at the University of
Chicago on eminent eminent evolutionary
biologist who and I'm sure you will
experience this if you go to any of your
biology professors who actually never
read the Origin of Species now he had to
teach a class an undergraduate class
which although it happens occasionally
senior professors in science don't often
descend to teach undergraduates but he
did and he decided that he would assign
the Origin of Species and so he read it
for the first time himself and we met
each other on the sidewalk in front of
the University and he stopped me and he
said Bob you know old Darwin really knew
a lot of biology well he did other
questions this is not the common view
the ones I presented to you that you
find of Darwin's accomplishments so this
is as I say it's a rather heterogeneous
analysis but you good readers of text
presumably will now have ammunition so
there's a question right there to
confront those who think otherwise how
would you respond to the deep ecologist
who might say that I believe in the
science of evolution but this discovery
of an anthropocentric moral occult in
Darwin privileges the human over the
nonhuman and this is a kind of
ontological violence against nature
itself well I think my response would be
my mind
of course we are interested in that
particular animal species of which we
are members and we want to understand as
much as we can I mean in congressional
legislative hearings you hear some of
our more eminent senators and
congressmen a querying about research in
science and one of not some time ago now
but one of the queries had to do is why
we are giving so much money so much
money to study fruit fly genetics who in
the hell cares about fruit fly genetics
well of course in a certain sense we
don't care about fruit fly genetics we
care about human genetics but the best
way to understand human genetics is to
look at fruit flies where the processes
are simpler and more easily graspable so
I guess at the same sense I would say
but look what we we are interested in
other animals but is it a mistake to be
even more interested in ourselves and
the processes that govern us we differ
from other animals but one of the ways
in which we differ I think is pretty
clear is that we have a moral structure
and it did seem problematic and some
eminent evolutionary biologists would
say that look what evolution teaches us
is that we are ultimately selfish we
have been produced by natural selection
and natural selection is a selfishly
operating principle it selects those
four traits that are beneficial to the
individual it's simply a facade that
kind of moral character that we
sometimes parade we are ultimately
selfish well I think Darwin had another
perspective on that and I respect ofwhat
well worth considering and I think
there's a good deal of empirical
evidence in doing studies of human
behavior to support that so to that
radical ecologist I would say well sure
we're interested in all sorts of animals
but we're interested in the traits that
we exemplify as well and one of those is
moral character
why don't you wait you've stressed the
importance of reading the text carefully
and by doing so coming to these
conclusions of a different view of
Darwin a different view Darwin yeah
would you say that the Neo the Neo
Darwinists and Stephen Gould and other
people that you've mentioned do you
think that that is in some way dangerous
to the intellectual discourse do you
what do you think of its effect in a
wider and in the wider kind of you know
the way that people perceive I mean it's
a bigger question but what do you think
it's doing too well I had a colleague
who some time ago wrote a an essay for a
prominent scientist for the journal
science as a matter of fact history of
science should be x-rated because if you
really understood the way science worked
and not the way that it's portrayed in
say the first couple paragraphs of any
biology text that you pick up a science
book that you pick up you would see that
it is not as portrayed we have an ideal
of the notion of the way science works
but the way that it actually works is a
lot Messier and it's actually quite
beneficial to teach neophytes like
yourselves
the ideal - something to strive for
if they saw the way science actually
worked in this messy way so for it I
just to give you a random example it has
been argued that Gregor Mendel the
individuals who the individual who
really gave foundation for our
contemporary notion of the gene Mendel
had noticed that there are certain
ratios of outcome in the production of
hybrid peas but when you looked at the
ratios the Mendelian ratios that he
concluded - they seem to be too perfect
they were too good
so the question is did Mendel sort of
fidget with the outcome that is did he
have already an ideal outcome determined
mathematically and then looked at the
empirical outcome and really gave you
what the results were of his
mathematical demonstration and not the
empirical support for that mathematical
demonstration well gregor mendel was a
monk and probably he was quite sensitive
about honesty so we'll just give him
that it's very likely though that when
he was counting peas so it it's
important he was looking at this
characteristic wrinkled Peas versus
smooth Peas now if you're counting you
might say okay
wrinkled goes in that basket smooth goes
and that one wrinkled in that smooth
than that this smoother wrinkled well I
know I need a 1 2 3 ratio it's wrinkled
so if that's the way science really does
work and and if you've worked in a
laboratory you know there's a lot of
massaging of data and so forth that's
not the sort of thing that you want to
have as the ideal and the way science
operates so you're you're willing to
provide the ideal reading the text of
Darwin that's your original question
that's what you guys have the
opportunity of doing and I have to say
that Columbia University as I mentioned
initially and Chicago are one of the
very few major universities where this
kind of education is taken so very
seriously and it is the kind of
equipment that you are being given
that's going to hold you in very good
stead later on it's going to help you
read critically and not be taken in by
just because some famous or infamous
person said x y&z are you going to take
their word for it it's going to teach
you a kind of critical scepticism which
i think is beneficial for all of us to
have so reading text carefully is going
to be a good idea
and it does undermine a little bit the
ordinary conception that we've had of
Darwin but you can you can distinguish
Charles Darwin the individual from
Darwin the icon Darwin the icon serves
many purposes in contemporary biology I
mean biologists still pay obeisance to
that icon but we have to remember there
was a historical Darwin behind that icon
thank you very much
you